vous n'avez jeu pour ce suicide le
malaise dans la police
ils touchent toute la profession depuis
des décennies au quotidien les agents se
confronte à la misère et à la violence
de la société avec des moyens
insuffisants à les écouter
ce ras-le-bol ils l'expriment depuis des
années 70 où les raisons tiennent
essentiellement aux moyens aux
conditions de travail
il ya à peu près un véhicule pour 15
nous n'avons pas de matériel radio les
inspecteurs de police dispose à peu près
d'une machine à écrire pour trois ans le
même sentiment s'exprime en 1980 sont
des moyens du bord avec ce cône à risque
on peut manière un illuminateur commun
c'est l'argent et et d'argent lille
mais ce n'est pas grand chose comparé à
1996 une année noire dans la police
française 70 suicides d'agents sont
recensés un bang tous les cinq jours et
la seconde on pète les plombs on alarme
chez soi comme tous les collègues blancs
chez 90% de chances qu'on prenne un pour
se suicider le malaise est profond au
manque de moyens ça joue tout le stress
et les heures interminables la france
autant plan vigipirate après une vague
d'attentats
la police est à bout les autorités ne
peuvent plus le nier
nous voulions voir comment faire en
sorte d'éviter ces drames si c'est
possible
et de mettre toute notre activité tout
autre passion toute notre volonté pour
faire en sorte que ça se trouve elle
le moins possible la solution du
ministre de l'intérieur celle écoute
fait émane des 96
il met en place le service de soutien
psychologique opérationnel qui existe
encore aujourd'hui
les policiers ont besoin de parler de ce
qu'ils ont vécu des émotions qui ont été
mises en oeuvre pour pouvoir les gérer à
titre préventif et pour rester
opérationnels nouveau coup dur aux les
forces de l'ordre en 2015
entre les attentats de charlie hebdo du
13 novembre l'état d'urgence la coop 21
les agents ont été très sollicités au
point d'annuler des congés et des
formations
à partir du moment où vous ne cessez
bien d'accumuler les missions ou qu'elle
dure de plus en plus longtemps et bien
physiologiquement les policiers ne sont
pas des robots
et donc il faut bien un moment qu'il se
ressource qu'il se repose et en
l'occurrence aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement difficile eu égard aux
nombreuses missions qu'il faut assurer
en réaction le service de soutien
psychologique a été renforcée mais ce
que demander et demandent toujours des
policiers ce sont des renforts matériels
et surtout humains l'année 2019 réveille
les douloureux souvenirs de 1996
[Musique]